I have amazing news that is also sort of
disappointing news Stephen Colbert on
the CBS Late Show with Stephen Colbert
talked about Melania Trump liking a
tweet with a David Pakman show video
questioning how she got her Einstein
visa he did this late last week Friday
night on national television that's the
good news
the downside is that the David Pakman
show is not actually mentioned at any
point so let me catch you up on this
entire thing we're now about ten days
ago we did a story questioning how
Melania Trump got an e b1 visa also
known as an Einstein visa also known as
an extraordinary ability visa and a few
days later a Twitter user named David M
rod tweeted a link to that video and the
official verified Melania Trump Twitter
account with nearly a million followers
liked the video by the next morning that
like had been removed and it was no
longer under the list of liked videos by
Melania Trump and this triggered a ton
of news articles about this including
one in Newsweek and a whole bunch of
other articles and the articles
mentioned specifically the liked tweet
was one of a video from the David Pakman
show it explained our position on the
hypocrisy of this visa given Donald
Trump's immigration ideas all well fine
and good and then the story gets picked
up by Stephen Colbert on his late-night
talk show and he talked about the liking
of the tweet
they showed a screenshot of the Newsweek
article on the screen but sadly no
mention of the fact that this was all
related to a video on the David Pakman
show here's a bit of the video from
Stephen Colbert this week it got even
worse when Melania liked a tweet calling
Trump a hypocrite on his immigration
policies titled how exactly did Melania
Trump get an Einstein visa yes
Melania may be questioning her own
citizenship relations between her and
Donald have gotten so bad she's hoping
ice will intervene so yes the tweet said
how exactly did without Melania Trump
get an Einstein visa that was our video
title but no mention of the David Pakman
show or
our video it's a missed opportunity I'm
sort of bummed about it I don't really
think Stephen Colbert did anything wrong
I'm not mad there's no conspiracy to
avoid mentioning the David Pakman show
but it was an opportunity we could have
just as easily been mentioned as as
easily as we weren't mentioned I guess
is my point
it was our video title there and in the
end it's not like we broke the story
about milania's Einstein visa right we
covered it and it happened to be our
video that Melania Trump's Twitter
account liked so listen it was a valiant
effort I hope that I we have another
opportunity to be featured on the
Stephen Colbert show not because I
committed some strange and depraved
crime but because of something positive
that took place on the show and a lot of
people on the David Pakman show
subreddit believed that there was some
deliberate effort made here
not to mention independent media but I
don't think that's the case at all yeah
I guess there are two ways to look at it
one is that Stephen Colbert is trying to
set up his joke quickly just to get to
the punchline yeah and you know we got
left out sure the sceptical way to look
at it is that legacy media is just
ignoring us because they see us as
beneath them yeah and even more cynical
I would say arguably that that that
would be the perspective yeah I don't
think it's the latter I think it's just
it was not necessary to include us in
order to get to the joke he was telling
and by the way I tuned out as soon as
the Melania Trump and uh impersonator
came out I immediately stopped caring
yeah I didn't think that was that funny
it wasn't better I think if they showed
clips of the show yeah
like pointed out this is what Melania
Trump liked on Twitter that's bizarre
that would have been much better for us
that's for sure yeah but not that not
the way it went send me your thoughts
check out the clip online you can see it
in its entirety I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month
and every dollar helps to support the
work that we're doing particularly in
light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad